Musik
Hey, guten Tag, hallo, erst willkommen. Schön, dass ihr da seid. Herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast Ufo, der Podcast für euch. Natürlich mit Steven Titz und Stephen Florentin. Wie heißt es nochmal, Florentin Will? Richtig, das bin ich. Schön, dass ihr da seid. Herrlich, dass ihr da zusammengekommen seid, dass ihr uns alle... Boah, du hast einen starken Namen im englischen Film gerade auch. Will. Will, ja, das stimmt. Will. Mein Bruder hat oft erzählt, dass wenn er im Ausland arbeitet, dass er dann, wenn er gefragt wird, wie heißt er, sagt er einfach nur Will. Das heißt, er nimmt einfach direkt den Nachnamen als Vornamen. Also wie Zendaya quasi. Dein Bruder war Zendaya. Heißt sie Charlotte Zendaya? Ich weiß es gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Und dann sagt sie, skip the Charlotte. Charlize. Charlize Zendaya. Ne, let's skip it. Ja, ich glaube schon, dass sie so heißt. Ja, schön, dass wir uns wieder treffen, dass es so einrichten konnte. Dass ihr alle unter unserer kuscheligen Decke Platz gefunden habt. Es wird ja herbstlich, es wird ja kühler. Da kommen alle mal ein bisschen zusammen und knuddeln uns so ein bisschen. Ich bin so happy, dass es wieder Herbst ist. Ich bin so happy, das Jahr ging so schnell rum. Und irgendwie, das ist ja so diese Floskel, die ältere Menschen sagen, das Leben irgendwie jedes Jahr geht immer ein bisschen schneller rum, habe ich das Gefühl, das wurde nur oft gesagt, und als Kind noch viel zu entdecken, Tage kommen länger vor, es ist wirklich jetzt langsam, fliegt einfach alles, und es ist schon wieder ein Jahr später. Ich war noch neunzehn, gestern gefühlt, jetzt bin ich dreissig geworden dieses Jahr. Du wirst dreissig dieses Jahr? Bin schon. Machst du da was? Ich wurde schon dreissig. Hast du da was gemacht? Ja. War es was? Es war was. Also und ich war nicht dabei, oder was? Nein, du warst nicht dabei. Ich wurde gar nicht eingeladen und gefragt, oder was? Ich bin so froh, wir kennen uns so gut, dass ich dich gar nicht in die Bredouille bringe, absagen zu mir. Das ist schön von dir, das ist nett. Das ist mein Geschenk an dich gewesen. Das ist nett. Von dir habe ich auch kein Geschenk bekommen. Das ist so gut, dass ich mich unterordne deinem Regime, deinem Moralregime, aber ich mag Geschenke. Ich mag auch Geburtstagsgrüsse. Okay, also jetzt sagst du ja doch wieder, also wenn du jetzt sagst, mir zur Liebe lässt du mich gar nicht ein, aber jetzt baust du ja schon sowas wie einen emotionalen Druck auf, der auf mir lastet wie ein Stück Beton. Das stimmt, das stimmt, ne? Weil derjenige, der die Emotionen hat, ist immer der Gelackmeierte. Richtig, ja. Muss man schon so sagen. Ja, das stimmt schon, macht dich angriffslustig. Weil ich mag das Geschenk, ich mag das, wenn man mir gratuliert, wenn man an mich denkt, dass diese Bürde will ich eigentlich nicht aufladen, weil du das nicht magst, diese ganzen Sachen. Ich mag es am liebsten in Ruhe. Ich sage den Leuten, wenn ihr mir was Gutes tun wollt zum Geburtstag, dann lasst mich in Ruhe an dem Tag und nervt mich mit euren Emotionen und Wünschen und Huldigungen, dann bitte erst am nächsten Tag wieder. Aber schön. Ach, nervt doch nicht. Danke, ja, Sie können gehen. Der Parkplatz ist eigentlich, der ist privat, der Parkplatz. Das ist wirklich, ich zahle 80 Euro im Monat. Ich zahle 80 Euro im Monat für diesen Parkplatz. Menschen haben Laternen gebastelt, mit Florentins Kopf, haben so Masken auf, also vorm Gesicht. Florentin will, Florentin will, Florentin will. Ja, wie gesagt, das ist eine Einfahrt, das ist eine Einfahrt. Schatz, Florentin, was ist da draußen los? Ach, die Leute huldigen mir wieder, heute ist ja der Florentintag und die Huldigung. Sie erwarten das Kommen des grossen Messias oder was auch immer. Er ist ein Fenster, er ist ein Fenster! Könnt ihr bitte schauen, dass wir nicht nicht in dem Blumenbeet. Hey, könnt ihr nicht im Blumenbeet bitte stehen, das sind alles Rosalien. Wie ist das Opfer für dich? Ach, Leute, das ist... Ach Gott, lasst mich doch einfach in Ruhe. Und dann wird dir wieder ein Lamm geschächtet. Ja, wieder diese Lamm-Schächtung. Hat sich wirklich jemals jemand darüber gefreut, dass ein Lamm geschächtet wurde? Also hat Zeus gesagt, oh, yippie, Lammblut, ich liebe es. Der hätte auch gesagt, wer zur Hölle ist auf die Idee gekommen? Nee, ich glaube schon, dass du, wenn du merkst, Leute gehen für dich weit. Und ein Lamm durch die Meere, ein Lamm oder Kalb, also meinend Babytiere zu töten, ist schon wirklich weit zu gehen. Und wenn wirklich, da will ich dich mal sehen. Jetzt sagst du hier, bist du die moralische Anhöhe, aber eigentlich der moralische Huppel, Nübel, bist du gerade? Aber dann will ich mal sehen, wenn eine Menschengruppe dir ein Lamm schächtet. Ich glaube, das ist so wie bei so, wenn man einmal sagt, man mag Marzipan, irgendwie so im Nebensatz und dann kriegt man den Rest seines Lebens Marzipan geschenkt. Ich glaube, so ist es mit dem Geschächten Lamm auch, dass man einmal sagt so, ach, bei der Lamm schächtet bin ich gerne dabei. So und dann kriegt Zeus halt die letzten, die nächsten dreitausend Jahre jede Woche ein Lamm geschächt und ist so, irgendwann ist auch durch so. Also ich glaube, wenn du genug davon isst oder konsumierst oder wie auch immer da die Lammsäle, was damit dann durchgewurstet wird, glaube ich, hast du auch genug. Alles hängt dir irgendwann zum Hals raus. Irgendwann musst du auch mal sagen, magst du das? Das war so schnell postmäßig. Ehrlich gesagt, in Hammfechten zum Beispiel. Das kann auch sein, ja. Und dann wurde daraus halt schnell Lammschächten. Lammschächten, ja, ja. Was für Gott, in Hammfechten, ja, in Lammschächten.
Okay, alles klar, ich kümmere mich um das Lamm. Nochmal, so. Damals war die Leitung noch nicht gut. Muss man auch können, das ist auch ein Berufsstand, der ausstirbt, der Schächter, ne, also dass so ein Lamm einfach, einfach wirklich mit so einem, mit so einem schnellen Hieb, auch mit der Handkante teilweise, zack, ist ja nicht so leicht, ne. Ich mein nur, du du siehst, das läuft ja alle drum, wenn man da die Kehle die schrägte, die macht, wenn man die Rieche aufhängt, dann die da alle drüber, oder? So, das hätte ich auch können. Deswegen immer, aber gar keine Beilagen oder so, also nichts gegen Lamm, jetzt herrlich, köstlich, aber irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Nudeln oder Pommes oder so, keine Ahnung. Naja, aber ich finde, wenn du ein Lamm opferst, kannst du dir dann auch, keine Ahnung, sowas wie Nudelsalat einfach beilegen. Also ich als Zeus würde mich nicht freuen. Stell dir mal vor, du kriegst so einen Teller mit so einem Haufen Lammfleisch. Nein, nein, nein. Ich meine, das ist ungewürzt, kein Ketchup, Sriracha. Aber die läuft, das passt ja mit uns zusammen, offensichtlich. Du musst es abschlucken, weil das ist kein Ketchup. Okay, verraten. Oh, keine, oh, keine. Nein, aber es ist halt nicht der Mittelpunkt. Also warum sollte man den Nudelsalat erwähnen? Nudelsalat wird nicht erwähnt. Beilagen werden nicht erwähnt. Ach so, du meinst, das kommt nicht in die Bibel. Was kam alles nicht in die Bibel? Wäre eine Beilage erwähnt, wäre die Hauptlage. Wer ist die Hauptspeise? Weißt du, was ich meine? Ach so, du meinst, man bestellt ja auch, ich hätte gerne Currywurst und du kriegst Currywurst mit Pommes. Was dabei ist. Du bestellst es nicht. Ja, CPM. Hab ich nämlich mal gemacht bei McDonalds, da war ich nämlich in Nürnberg. Da dachte ich mir, komm, jetzt gehst du mal die Nürnberger Kultur richtig auskosten. Bin ich zu McDonalds gegangen und die hatten da gerade eine Aktion, Shrimp mit Dip. Und, ähm, also Shrimps mit so einem Cocktail-Dip. Ja. Und dann bin ich in die Kasse und habe gesagt, ich hättektion, Shrimp mit Dip. Und, ähm, also, Shrimps mit so einem Cocktail-Dip.
Und dann bin ich in die Kasse und habe gesagt, ich hätte gerne einmal Shrimp mit Dip.
Und ich so, mit was? Dip. Wie Dip?
Ja, so wie es da steht, Shrimp mit Dip.
Ohne Scheiß, wenn das da steht, muss es verstanden werden.
Die Leute haben immer gesagt, ich hätte gerne einmal die Shrimps, die McShrimps,
die auch nicht irgendwie McShrimp hießen, sondern einfach nur Shrimps mit Dip. Was mich schön rausgeworfen hat, weil du bist in diesem Mac drin. Mein Tipp an McDonalds, kleiner Einschub, mein Dip, mein Tipp an McDonalds, kleiner Einschub, cut the Mac. Was? Nein. Donalds. Ich hätt gern einmal die Achter Chicken Nuggets. Ja. Und der ganze McDonalds wird still. Und alle Augen finden dich. Und du, was? Nee, ich sag, Cut the Mac. Cut the Mac. Das ist die Werbung. Ich will ein Big. Ich hätte gerne ein Big, Chicken Nuggets, und Chicken. Das funktioniert überhaupt nicht. Das funktioniert für mich überhaupt nicht. Nein, das brauchst du. Ein Rip. Was krieg ich? Und McDonalds. Einfach ein McDonalds. Und es ist einfach ein grosses D. Obendrauf. Meinerwege, lass das M. Alle wissen doch, wo es herkommt. Ja. Danke. Für weitere Tipps einfach mal im TikTok-Account, Business-Tipps, Stefan, Business-Tipps. Das stimmt, du hast schon viele Top-100-Filmen, Forbes, ganz nach oben geforbt. Also da kamen ja teilweise 20 junge Start-Ups, auch und Rundfunkunternehmen. Ja, wie Amazon. Wie Amazon, ja. Die hießen erst Mac Amazon. Richtig, und dann hast du ihnen den Weg geöffnet. Cut the Mac. Cut the Mac, just cut it. Cut alles. Ich musste leider gestern eine traurige Stunde, weil ich hatte nichts mehr zu essen zu Hause. Ich hatte nichts mehr geplant, meine Planung ist schiefgegangen, ich habe irgendwo einen Anschluss verpasst, kam nicht rechtzeitig.
und dann stehst du plötzlich da und hast dich selber ins Abseits manövriert und hast gemerkt,
oh Gott, ich habe gar keine Verbündeten mehr im Kühlschrank, ich stehe alleine da auf weiter Flur,
ich muss jetzt alleine Schottland verteidigen und dann guckt man halt, was man noch so hat. Und das ist eigentlich Momente, die ich gerne mag, weil ich mir denke, okay, jetzt entstehen neue Ideen. Jetzt, wenn man halt nicht sich Spaghetti Bolognese machen kann, dann muss man jetzt was Neues erfinden. Ja, geht aber nur, wenn du in den Kühlschrank einen Grundstock hast. Oder man schaut mal in den Schränken nach. Ich bin ja auch gerne mal dann so ein Schrankwühler. Da sind manchmal Schätze. Da sind manchmal Schätze, nicht oft Kaffeefetze. Und mit Schätze meine ich abgelaufene Nudelsuppen. Wie man dann immer so als Kind in den Schränken rumgewühlt hat und dachte, kann ich Kaffeefilter essen? Die sehen aus wie dünne Waffeln. Wo man dann so Bock auf Süßigkeiten hatte als Kind, so Bock auf Süßigkeiten, dass man sich so Tic Tacs oder so Minz gegessen hat. Oder so Zuckerwürfel einfach. Ja, was ist da dann falsch mit der Menschheit? Ich glaube, ich habe auch einmal versucht, eine Kaffeebohne zu essen. Obwohl ich als Kind schon wusste, ich mag keinen Kaffee. Aber ich dachte, die Bohne hatte so was M&Miges oder so was Schokoresiniges. Du meinst die Haptik? Ja, irgendwie. Und dann hat es, war schrecklich. Und dann guckt man halt, was man so im Schrank hat. Und dann habe ich noch eine Dose Mais. So. Wie läuft schon wieder das Wasser? Ich reibe mir das Beuchlein gerade. Das ist lustig, man kann bei Flo und die Wichtbeobachtung, sobald du bei Essen redest, kriegst du so einen ganz feuchten Hört euch jetzt nicht noch mal alle vierunderdreissig Episoden an und haltet danach ausschauernd. Wir hören mal eine rein. Da habe ich mit einem und einem gegessen. Und Ja, das waren die älteren Folgen. Ja, kann sein, dass das noch ein bisschen mehr war, früher auf jeden Fall. Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, okay, ich habe im Kühlschrank noch ein bisschen Käse, geriebenen Käse, Gratin-Käse habe ich noch ein bisschen dabei. Warum denn nicht mal schön Mais mit Käse kombinieren, ja, also hat das schon mal jemand gemacht? Maiskäse. Maiskäse, Käse-Mais, einfach mal schön die Dose in den. Das verlorene Rezept. Das war dochne Rezept, man hat es versucht zu entziffern auf irgendwelchen alten Granittafeln aus Pompeji und es war immer Mais-Äse und niemand was. Sir, es macht keinen Sinn, da steht Maiskäse, aber das passt gar nicht zusammen. Das kann man nicht zusammen essen, das geht nicht. Währenddessen, Cut zu mir, wie ich einfach sag, komm, schöne Handvoll Gratin-Käse. Die du nur Boxersorts an hast, also Kopfschuss auf und so laut ein Lied a cappella singst, deine Nachbarn denken, was ist mit ihm wieder los? Heute wird Geschichte geschrieben. Deine Nachbarn stellen mir immer so vor wie so, wie die von Schöne Bescherung bei den Griswolds Weihnachten, die so den gleichen so silbernen Future Jogginganzug haben, dann immer gemeinsam. Genau. Und wenn bei dir vorbeikommen und du liegst wieder in der Badewanne. Ja, die auch die perfekten Kinder haben, die einfach wie sie nur kleiner sind, der gleiche Anzug und alles. Mom, was macht der Nachbar wieder? Ach, frag nicht. Na ja, man könnte ja auch Popcorn in der Waschmaschine machen, weil das wird ja auch heiß. Die ganze Wohnung ist voller Popcorn. Was macht der Mann? Ach, frag nicht Neheresi oder so. So einen Namen, wo man denkt. Frag nicht Sethkoth. Und diesmal konnten sie mich dabei beobachten, wie ich einfach schön die Dose in den Topf gehauen habe, Dose Mais, Handvoll geriebenen Käse dazu. Handvoll geriebenen Käse, was Was ist das? Wo ist das? Salz, bisschen Salz,
Salz, Pfeffer, Löffel,
gemischt. Salz, Pfeffer,
Löffel, gemischt. Perfekt.
Dann rühre ich das so rum, denke mir, okay, das schmilzt
jetzt so rein, was? Also das schmilzt jetzt
durch die Wärme. Schmilzt gleich der Mais im
Käse?
Schmilzt das jetzt so richtig rein, schaue ich
rein, was sehe ich? Einen Klumpen
Blau. Hm? Einen Klumpen Blau. Farbe blau? Die Farbe blau. Ja. Nehmen wir, maisgelb, käsegelb. Blau. Käse, Blauschimmelkäse. War Schimmel. Der Käse war bereits geschimmelt. Boah, ich übergebe mich gleich. Und jetzt dachte ich, aber gut, da ist ja nur der eine Brocken, ne? Also, naja, du hast ja so eine Handvoll Gratenkäse. Und da, klar, irgendwo da unten drunter, wenn du tief genug gräbst, ist immer irgendwo ein Stückchen Schimmel. So, ist ja immer irgendwo. Ist doch immer irgendwo ein bisschen. Dann denke ich mir, gut, dann löffel ich halt dieses Stück da raus. Währenddessen die Leute auf der Strasse, Florentin will, Florentin will, schächten ihm wieder ein Lamm, wird verehrt und du oben isst Schimmel mit dem Löffel.
Und dann habe ich überlegt, naja gut, kann man das noch essen? Was würdest du tun? Das ganze Gemisch weggippen. Also bin ich auch nicht stolz drauf, aber wenn Käse, das ist ein Hilferuf. Also der Käse ruft Töte mich, töte mich, kipp mich weg. Bring es zu Ende. Ich wurde vor drei Monaten gekauft, für einmal Spaghetti Bolognese hast du irgendwie einen kleinen Esslöffel von mir drüber gehauen über die Suppe und jetzt hänge ich hier rum und habe keinen Auftrag. Lebensmittel ist ja manchmal auch schon eher, bevor es überhaupt sichtbar ist, schon ruiniert. Sowas darfst du nicht sagen. Du hast mit dieser Aussage Tonnen von Lebensmitteln verschwendet, weil die Leute denken, die Pringles sehen zwar noch gut aus, aber Stefan Tietze hat gesagt, die sind oft schon, bevor man es sieht, verdorben. Noch oft, bevor man es kauft, sind die schon verdorben im Supermarkt. Ich dachte, es ist andersrum. Obwohl man denkt, sie sind verdorben, sind sie noch nicht verdorben.
Nee, das stimmt. Ich habe wahrscheinlich beides mal gehört, beides bei guten Dokus. Es kancelt sich raus, es kürzt sich raus. Irgendwo bleibt mein Mann plus minus null. Ich denke mir nur, wenn dein Käseleib irgendwo ein blaues, ich zitiere dich, ein blaues Schimmelfleckchen hat. das fängt ja nicht an bei blau, oft fängt es ja an mit weissen Stippen. Und wenn es irgendwann schon so ein blaues Herz aus Schimmel hat, so eine Schimmelkultur, die schon anfängt, so leichte Zivilisationsaspekte zu gründen. Du meinst nicht, man kann es einfach rausschneiden, das Römische Reich einfach zack nehmen mit so einer Greifhand und raus? Du meinst, die haben überall ihre Religionen schon und haben schon irgendwie Metastasen gebildet gebildet. Metastasen. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Dann habe ich mir überlegt, na gut, vielleicht muss ... Der Meiste ist ja noch gut. Meiste ist die letzte Dose, die ich habe. Ich habe ja sonst gar nichts mehr. Kann ich vielleicht das Ganze noch entkäsen? Habe ich nicht irgendwann mal so im Teleshopping mir einen Entkäser gekauft für viel Geld? Die gab es ja früher immer, wenn man nachts Fernsehen geschaut hat. Die Cheesy, ein Die Cheesy. Die Cheesy, dass man sagt so, wenn man sagt, okay, haben Sie was mit Käse überbacken? Hallo, mein Name ist Ingolf Lüngelbronn. Und ich bin Britta Hagedorn. Und wir präsentieren den Die Cheesy. Die Cheesy. Entschuldigung, wir haben den Namen noch mal kurz vor der Sendung geändert. Entschuldigung. Tut mir leid, Hagen. So uncool. Den D-Cheesy. Kennen Sie das auch? Sie haben etwas mit Käse backen und denken sich, oh nein, das wollte ich gar nicht, dann müssen Sie jetzt alles wegschmeissen und oder essen? Dann haben wir die perfekte Lösung für Sie. Den D-Cheesy. Sie werden einfach den Käse los. Wie funktioniert das Ganze? Erklär doch mal. Chemie, geballte Chemie, verschiedene Substrate aus Nitriten, Nitraten und Säuren schaffen es, den Käse wegzuätzen. Ignorieren sie den schwarzen Dampf, einfach die Fenster auf und schon ist das Problem beseitigt. Also der Käse ist im Dampf? Der Käse ist verdampft. Wo geht der Käse hin? Einfach in die Luft. Auf dem Fenster raus. Und dann ein paar Jahre später wurde es vom Lebensmittelamt gecancelt. Ja, weil irgendjemand das eingeatmet hat und dann selber Käse in der Lunge hatte und das alles verkäst wurde von innen. Und dann dachte ich mir, habe ich nicht irgendwo nochmal so einen Entkäser gekauft? Irgendwie guck halt so rum, Creppplatte, Sandwichmaker, Nicer Dicer, der Magic Bucket und da war er tatsächlich, der Endkäser.
Und da dachte ich mir, Gott, bevor ich den jetzt aufbaue, schmeiße ich alles weg. Habe alles weggeschmissen und bin hungrig ins Bett gegangen, beziehungsweise habe mir noch eine Tütensuppe gemacht und dann war es das auch für mich. Aber das sind die Momente im Leben, die man nicht wieder zurückkriegt. Hat mich schon gefreut, vielleicht war das so das Eingreifen des Universums, dass jemand sagt, oh, wenn die kurz davor sind, Käse Mais zu entdecken, muss jemand eingreifen, dann haut da ein bisschen Schimmel mit rein oder so, das ist ja für so eine Gottheit oder so kein Problem. Schimmel mit so einem Fingerschnipp, irgendwas schimmeln zu lassen, gibt es bestimmt eine Blieb. Hat jemand mal eine Liste gemacht, was Gott alles kann? Nee, allmächtig, das ist die Liste. Na gut, okay konkret, was heisst allmächtig? Ja, aber jetzt, also dann sollten wir eine Liste machen, mit dem, was er nicht kann. Gut, aber sorry, jetzt nichts gegen Gott. Aber wenn Gott allmächtig ist, warum gibt es dann andere Religionen? Das ist ja auch Gott. Das ist ja auch Gott. Also die Christen würden sagen, das ist ja auch Gott. Ja gut, aber der christliche Gott sagt jetzt gut, die sagen jetzt Vishnu, aber eigentlich bin das schon ich. Erst mal ganz ehrlich. Oh. Das ist schon mit die uncoolste Religion. Ist so symbolisch, optisch. Hinduismus? Nee, unser. Ach so, okay. Vielleicht aber, weil man es zu sehr gesehen hat und es ist so. Der Fisch ist ikonisch. Den Fisch finde ich halt zum Beispiel furchtbar. Taube, auch kein gutes Tier für ... Also, der brennende Busch, der ist doch geil. Weiß ich, habe ich noch nicht ganz verstanden, auch die Botschaft der brennenden Busch. Habe ich auch nicht 100% nicht verstanden. Aber so, erst mal so symbolisch, dann dieses super, immer dieses pathetische Kreuz, immer so leidendes Kreuz. das ist eine wahnsinnig leidende Religion, so wahnsinnig die Sünde für alle ans Kreuz genagelt, damit wir alle von unseren Sünden befreit wurden und die Beichte ist alles so heavy. Ja gut, aber dafür kannst du ja deine Ruhe haben, wenn der eine die Sünde alle aufnimmt. Ich habe letztens zum Beispiel eine sehr kurze Doku gesehen, also ein GIF hauptsächlich.
Aber ich hätte es nicht sagen müssen.
Ich hätte auch einfach sagen können, ich habe eine Doku gesehen.
Ich war so ehrlich und habe es eingegrenzt.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, warum das noch eine Rolle spielt.
Und da hiess es ja, in vielen Bauerngemeinden in Bayern, auch vielen Bauernbetrieben, Landwirtschaftsbetrieben, gibt es noch den uralten Brauch aus alter Zeit, dass man im Kuhstall einen Bock dazustellt, Ziegenbock. Der ist da dabei, also ganzer Stall voller Kühe, ein Ziegenbock. Warum? Der Teufel. Weil der die Krankheiten auf sich zieht. Das heißt, wenn der Bock vorhanden ist, der fungiert als Krankheits- oder Unglücksmagnet, zieht das alles auf sich und die Kühe bleiben gesund. Und dann meint der Bauer auch so, ja, ich will selber tut, das machen wir jetzt schon immer so, was du so, was du so, was du so, was du so. Das ist saubreich. Und dann dachte ich mir auch, okay, das ist auch so dieses Jesus-Konzept, einer zieht alles auf sich und alle anderen sind glücklich, aber natürlich auch so ein bisschen Teufel-Ding, ne, also der Ziegenbock ist ja auch so Teufelsgestalt, Satan, und das ist ja auch glaube ich so, also dass man diesen Ziegenböcken einfach nicht vertraut, zieht sich so ein bisschen durch. Ja, ich habe einen ganz schlimmen Film, The Witch, ja, ja, ja, er ist schon ein bisschen älter jetzt, neun Jahre jetzt, auch schon 2015, aber das ist wirklich ein ganz schlimmer Film gewesen, der mich nachhaltig verstärkt hat, weil sie hat irgendwann Spoiler Alert. Ja, jetzt zur Halloween-Zeit, pack den gerne mal wieder aus. Ich hab den privat Gruseltober genannt und ich bin ja so offensiv Gruseltober und ich wünsche euch das bitte auch. Nennt das Gruseltober, weil es ist so ein Schlecht, so irre schlecht. Und dann hat auch jemand zu mir gesagt, ja warum nicht Schocktober? Was? Nein. Nein, es ist der Gruseltober. Ja. Aber auch, das ist auch falsch getrennt. Oktober kommt wahrscheinlich nicht von Oktober, sondern von Oktober, ohne genau zu wissen, wahrscheinlich acht, wahrscheinlich war es mal der achte Monat. Ja, ja. September wahrscheinlich mal der neunte, äh, der siebte Monat.
Aber Toba ist ikonisch, du kannst eigentlich an alles Toba hängen, also du kannst auch
mal sagen, bei mir ist meist Toba oder so, Toba ist immer als Oktober bekannt, nichts
anderes endet auf Toba.
Ja, aber Okt ist ja wahrscheinlich der Präfix, deswegen ist es so albern, ich mag das aber
sehr und ich führe wirklich rigoros immer den Grusel Toba ein und es wird einfach, es
werden Horrorfilme geballert, die werden! In Köln! Oh ja! Mensch, Stefan, dir wachsen Haare. Deine Beine krümmen sich. Stimmt, das war das. Das habe ich schon mal letztes Jahr genauer. Boah, ist das schlimm. Ah, das ist ganz ruhig. Ich erinnere mich. Da gibt es dann auch so einen Apfel und sowas. Ich habe das nicht mehr so ganz in Erinnerung. Ja, okay. Ich hatte mal eine Phase. Ich fände wieder das Essen ein. Naja, das ist so eine Hexe. Da gab es aber nur Apfel. So eine Hexe natürlich auch, so was zu essen braucht, ist ja klar. Dann ist sie durchs Feuer gegangen. Knusprige. Knusprige Hexe. Ich hatte ja mal eine Phase, wo ich mich den Horrorfilm gestellt habe, aber dann habe ich gemerkt, ich habe einfach zu viel Angst, ich bin zu nervös, ich will das nicht sehen, ich kann mich da nicht konzentrieren. Und weil mein Vater mal gesagt hat, mein Vater und ich, anscheinend haben wir irgendwie mal was Gruseliges zusammengeschaut oder er wollte mich überzeugen und dann meinte ich, na, ich hab da immer ein bisschen Angst, irgendwie keine Ahnung, dann meinte mein Vater, wenn du in einem Film sitzt und du hast Angst, dann stell dir einfach die Dreharbeiten von dem Film vor. Stell dir vor, dass direkt neben dem Monster jemand steht mit einem Mikrofon, dass daneben jemand steht mit einem Klemmbrett und einer Kaffeetasse und sagt, Leute, das ist jetzt Take acht, wir müssen hier wirklich vor vier durch sein. Und dann sich umdreht und denkt, war da gerade ein Monster neben mir? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, und dann so, hey, PL, was war das denn gerade, ich weiß nicht, hat er nach rechts geguckt mit dem Klemmbrett? Ich habe gerade noch einmal mit dem Klemmbrett gegert geguckt, und nach rechts, komm, wir spielen nochmal zurück. Lass uns nochmal die Aufnahme durchschauen, ob da was ist. Moment mal, da ist nichts. Und ich denke, wir haben einen komplett eigenen Horrorfilm im Kopf. Ja, genau. Da ist nichts. Komm, spiel nochmal zurück. Und dann langsam sieht man hinten so einen Alien durchgehen und Florian sitzt vor dem Fernsehen. Ja, manchmal hilft die Taktik auf jeden Fall nicht, das stimmt, aber deswegen ist es bei mir fast schon, weil Horrorfilme basieren ja darauf, dass man schon eigentlich nicht jetzt die Angst hat, sondern man baut so hin auf die Angst, man denkt, gleich passiert was, gleich passiert was, gleich passiert was, und das heißt, noch bevor irgendwas wirklich Gruseliges passiert, bin ich schon in dem Modus Abwehr, Abwehr, Abwehr, Kissen vom Gesicht, Kissen vom Gesicht. Ich stell mir die Dreharbeiten vor und irgendwie, ah, der hat die Rolle, der hat sich bestimmt gefreut, als er die Rolle bekommen hat, so.
Der Typ, der jetzt gerade verstümm hat sich bestimmt gefreut, als er die Rolle
bekommen hat, so. Der Typ, der jetzt gerade
verstümmelt auf dem Boden liegt und schreit.
Der hat wahrscheinlich einen Anruf bekommen von seinem Agenten
und hat in seiner New Yorker Wohnung gesagt
Yes! Und dann hat er seine Freunde angerufen und ist trinken gegangen.
Und hat sich im Kugelspiegel
und sich hinter sich das Monster denkt.
Und deswegen,
in dem Modus will ich den gesamten Film üben, mit dem, ah, wie oft haben die das probiert, dass das Messer genau so da reingeht, das haben die bestimmt dreimal versucht und dann irgendwie nochmal Reshoots und so. Das heißt, ich krieg vom Film nahezu nichts mit, weil ich die ganze Zeit in dieser Produktionswelt bin irgendwie. Und dann schau ich mir gleich das Making-of an, dann kann ich mir auch einfach das Making-of anschauen. Das ist ein ähnlicher Effekt. Ich habe jetzt eine Serie gucken wollen. Das war eine öffentlich-rechtliche Produktion. Und es ist leider so, wie es häufig ist, wenn man den Moment verpasst, dann sind die nicht mehr in der Mediathek. Richtig. Mindest Verweildauer. Ich verstehe das nicht so richtig. Klar, hat sich richtige Gründe im Grundfunkstaatsverthalten. Aber ich verstehe es nicht genau. Kann ich dir erklären. Okay, ja, bitte. Und zwar, ich habe ein Referat drüber gehalten, weil ich sollte ja für die Referatenshow auf Rocket Beans TV, wo man auf zufälliger Wikipedia-Artikel klickt, muss man darüber ein Referat halten. Und ich habe einen öffentlich-rechtlichen Film bekommen, einen Fernsehfilm. Und dann wollte ich ihn anschauen, weil ich darüber ein Referat halten sollte, konnte ich nicht, gab es nicht mehr in der Mediathek. Da dachte ich mir, okay, mache ich doch ein Referat darüber, warum kann ich diesen Film nicht sehen? Mit Verweildauer. Das geht ja nicht so. Die Idee ist ja, dass du über den Ja, aber ich konnte ihn nicht sehen. Und da habe ich auch einiges an negativen Kommentaren bekommen, aber ich sage immer, mach was draus. Ich sage immer, jedes Problem ist nur ein, mach was draus. Und dann habe ich recherchiert und habe auch an den Twitter-Account von ZDF geschrieben und die haben auch geantwortet, haben mir das alles erklärt und die Idee ist ja, dass die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen einen Vorteil haben, weil sie Geld bekommen und keine Werbung machen müssen und egal was sie produzieren, sie haben immer genug Geld, wohingegen ProSieben muss gucken, dass sie genug Zuschauer haben, um Geld zu verdienen. Deswegen haben die einen ungerechten Vorteil, die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, den sie wieder kompensieren sollen, weil die Idee ist ja nicht, dass die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen die ganze Medienszene übernehmen, sondern dass sie einfach gleichberechtigt mit den Öffentlichen existieren, mit den privaten existieren. Und deswegen haben sie gesagt, wir müssen die nach einer Zeit wieder rausnehmen, weil sonst unsere Mediatheken so attraktiv und gut sind, dass niemand mehr Netflix oder ProSieben schaut. Ich bin aber jetzt der Meinung, dass es veraltet, es ist bescheuert, weil es wird wahnsinnig viel Geld ausgegeben für geile Sachen bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen. Ganz, ganz tolle Sachen. Und die sind einfach weg. Und die könnten so tolle Mediatheken haben und wir alle könnten uns viel sparen. Und klar, das ist ja der Punkt, den RTL dann macht und die Privatwirtschaft, aber es ist einfach absolut bescheuert. Also das führt nämlich jetzt dazu, dass alle sich der Privatwirtschaft zugewendet haben und da jetzt leicht verdaubare Dreckskacke konsumieren und wir alle langsam dumm werden und nur noch Scheiße vorgesetzt bekommen. Und das sage ich als jemand, der Teil des Problems ist. Ich will mich nicht inhaltlich distanzieren, ich will mich nur inzwischen ein bisschen strukturell vom ganzen Streaming kamen. Das wird aber auch wieder verlängert. Also ich habe da auch so einen Post gesehen, dass das Stück für Stück verlängert wird und vielleicht wird das auch irgendwann komplett abgeschafft. Aber da bräuchte es mal einen Mutigen, der entweder mal die ARD-Archive stürmt und das alles öffentlich verfügbar macht. Ich denke an dich. Du hast dein Ninja-Outfit, du hast dein Enterhaken, den du, glaube ich, zweimal benutzt hast und hast extra diesen Enterhaken kurz gemacht. Aber ich habe auch meine Steppschuhe. Du hast die Steppschuhe, die musst du ja nicht anziehen. Das sind die einzigen, die optisch zum Autofür passen. So, und deswegen braucht es da einen Mutigen auf jeden Fall oder eine Revolution. Komplett Camouflage, aber Steppschuhe. Also das Problem ist nämlich ... Was wolltest du sehen? Du wolltest eine Horrorserie im öffentlich-rechtlichen sehen. Du bist immer noch bei Horror. Nein, nein, nein. Ich wollte eine Serie gucken. Ah, und der Horror war, dass du sie nicht sehen konntest. Vergiss den Horror. Darüber haben wir vor einer halben Stunde gesprochen. Wir sind im Gruseltower. Ich bin bereit, mich zu gruseln. Gruselig fand ich der Horror, dass es nicht zu sehen war. Ah, jetzt habe ich es. Ah, okay. Aber da musst du am besten daran denken, dass so eine Mediathek einfach auch von Leuten produziert wird. Also wenn du Angst davor hast ... Die Nacht in so einem stillen, dunklen Raum sitzen und diese Mediathek programmieren. Genau, stell dir vor. Und sich dann umgucken und dann ist da ein Dämon. Scheiße, jetzt ist der Herr da falsch. Warum schreien die alle wie Homer Simpson, wenn er sich erschreckt? Aber so schreit man, glaube ich, wirklich. So schreit man wirklich, ja. Ich habe Angst, dass die Videoaufnahme abbricht.
Warum?
Weiß ich nicht, eine perfide Angst. Keine Sorge, keine Sorge. Weil wir sind auch bei Patreon zu sehen, wenn alles gut läuft, kann man uns da als Video sehen. Ne, genau, mein Horror ist, ich habe dann diese Serie nicht gefunden, wollte die aber ganz gerne gucken, hat mich thematisch sehr interessiert. Und damals habe ich die mal durch Umstände zwei Folgen davon gesehen, fand die ganz toll, wollte die immer mal zu Ende gucken, habe sie vergessen. Und jetzt, das ist ja auch so das Ding, die machen auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel Werbung dafür. Direkt runterladen. Ich habe mittlerweile wirklich eine Festbatte mit öffentlich-rechtlichen Sachen, die ich mir runterlade, weil ich mir denke, einfach Download. Screen Grab. Nein, nein, nein, da gibt es Programme und Möglichkeiten, Stefan. Da gibt es Programme und Möglichkeiten? Da bin ich mal ein bisschen Daddy. Nenn mich da bei solchen Sachen ruhig. Ich nenne mich da gerne Daddy. Daddy. Ja, so. Und tatsächlich, ihr habt ein Programm besorgt, das, oh, ich finde es immer noch so toll, weil du kennst ja so Programme, die du eigentlich einmal benutzen willst und irgendwie nicht genau weißt, wie oft benutze ich die, funktioniert das überhaupt? Und dann gab es die Möglichkeit, möchten Sie ein Abo abschliessen, das jeden Monat abbucht? Alle drei Monate oder alle sechs Monate? Kennt man ja, es wird dann immer billiger pro Monat, wenn man sich länger committet. Und dann gab es aber auch eine Option, einmalige Zahlung. Du zahlst einmal Geld und darfst es den Rest seines Lebens benutzen. Und das habe ich gemacht und das war die beste Entscheidung meines Lebens.
Eine Million Dollar.
Das war die beste Entscheidung meines Lebens.
Deswegen nochmal an der Stelle Patreon.
Also wie gesagt, mit den Videos bei Patreon.
Da könnt ihr entweder einklicken,
dass ihr uns, lieber Patreon, so
einmal im Monat unterstützt, ihr könnt
aber auch für Lifetime. Das wäre dann
eine Million Dollar. Genau.
Und da habe ich eine Million Dollar bezahlt, das ist glaube ich
zwei Jahre her, also ich glaube mittlerweile habe ich es schon
Vielen Dank. einmal im Monat unterstützt, ihr könnt aber auch für Lifetime. Das wären dann eine Million Dollar. Genau. Und da habe ich eine Million Dollar bezahlt, das ist glaube ich zwei Jahre her, also ich glaube mittlerweile habe ich es schon fast wieder drin, die monatlichen Kosten und damit kannst du alles runterladen und damit habe ich mir auch öffentlich-rechtliche Sachen runtergeladen, weil es gab ein paar Sachen, die habe ich richtig gut gefunden und dachte mir, sobald die weg sind, mache ich meine ARB oder BR... Du machst Mediathek XTO auf. Ich mache BRD, nicht ARD, sondern BRD. GmbH, noch sowas, oder sowas. Irgendwie in den Philippinen angemeldet oder so. Punkt PH. BRD.ph mache ich dann, wo ich dann alles hochlade, was ich gespeichert habe. Die konsequentere Sache wäre eine Antwort auf Kinox.to, Mediathek.xto.
Das stimmt, ja.
Und dann hast du Florentin oder wer auch immer, Zwinkel, Zwinkel. Wer auch immer der Pier ist. Wir wissen nicht, wer Pier ist.
Haben ja auch viele andere, haben alle Sachen runtergeladen, laden sie jetzt auf Mediathek.xto hoch.
Korrekt, ja.
So, wir wissen es nicht, liebe Anwälte, wir wissen es nicht, wir wissen es nicht.
Es war nicht Florentin, vielleicht schon.
Nein, nein.
Nee, aber genau das habe ich gesucht. Und dann habe ich die Serie tatsächlich gefunden. Und zwar bei archive.org. Oh, wow. Einer Seite, die ich für sehr mysteriös halte. Finde ich auch. Ja, auch diese Wayback-Maschinen und so, die alles archivieren. Das ganze Internet-Excuser mehr. Ich raff's wirklich nicht. Wo ist denn der Server von archive.org? Wahrscheinlich, wenn man sich den internationalen Stromverbrauch anschaut, dann hat man irgendwie USA, Grönland, Bitcoin, Google und dann archive. Einfach 70 Prozent der Torte ist archive.com. Ich glaube, wenn man auf der Rückseite des Mondes guckt, ist da eine riesige Dark Side of the Moon Server Farm und das ist alles archive.org. Das kann gut sein, da ist es sicher, da ist es sicher. Da finde ich es nämlich auch, sicher, niemand guckt da hin. Ja, ja, archive.moon, kommst du da hin. Boah, und dann habe ich die Serie da gefunden, weil, ähm, und das war, wirkte auch recht legal, was aber nur an dem Logo liegt, weil, was heißt, so ein so ein, so ein, also das ist ja die meisten, also das meiste vom Jurastudium kann man ja eigentlich sich sparen mit der einfachen Regel, je besser das Logo, desto legaler das Angebot, also das ist ja logisch. Oft, aber ehrlich, es ist eine gute Faustregel. Wenn du kein Gesetzbuch zur Hand hast, ist es oft die beste Faustregel.
Gutes Logo, gleich legal.
Ja, und es hat dieses, so ein Justitia, es ist so ein Akropolis, ein alter Tempel. Es ist das Logo von archive.org. Und das wirkt es... Riechen vertrauenswürdig. Finde ich voll. Auf jeden Fall. Und da habe ich die Serie gefunden. Allerdings nur mit Audiodeskription. Oh nein! Der geht zum Schrank. Und diese Serie finde ich auch wahnsinnig wichtig für mich und ein Projekt, was ich gerade verfolge. Du wirst nicht drumherum kommen, irgendwann zu sagen, wie diese Serie heisst, Stefan. Ich schreibe keine Serie. Nein, wie die, die du gesehen hast, heisst. Ach so. Weil du kannst nicht ewig drüber reden. Ich mag die ganz gern, äh, Bauhaus. Die neue Zeit. Und wir hatten mit dem Premiere. Nein, nein, nein, mit, ähm. War da nicht was? Das habe ich mal kurz gesehen, ne, August Diel? Ja, August Diel. August Diel, so. Ja, ja, August Diel. Irgendwas ist die Glorious Bastards halt. Ja, die Serie ist von Lars Kraume. Guter, guter Kerl, der hat auch Trash gemacht, aber das ist ganz gut. Und Bauhaus geht um, das heißt die neue Zeit, und es geht darum, um das Bauhaus in die Bewegung und wie sie das alles gegründet hat und dann auch kaputt gegangen ist und die politisch verfolgt wurden von den Nazis dann, die dann so aufkamen, weil mal Republikende, bla bla bla. Ganz, ganz spannende Serie, gucke ich, bin jetzt noch mittendrin, gucke den Anfang ganz gerne. Aber jetzt keine klassische Horror-Serie, oder würde ich sagen? Wie gesagt, das ist nicht mit Horror zu tun, der Horror ist rein digital. Ach so, okay. Wir hatten mit denen Premiere in Cannes, deswegen da habe ich nämlich zwei Folgen von denen gesehen. Aber da waren es noch Feinde, oder? Also jetzt hast du es langsam durchgekaut und jetzt hast du es jetzt kann ich mich endlich wieder dieser Kunst nähern. Ja, und das gibt es aber nur mit Audiodeskription. Und das ist super interessant, weil ich hätte noch nie was mit Audiodeskription geguckt. Das ist für blinde Menschen, die das nicht sehen können. Deswegen wird nochmal auf der Audiospiel erklärt, was auf dem Bild passiert. Walter Gropius sitzt auf einer Chaiselon. Er legt das Buch nieder. Er schaut auf. Es klingelt an der Tür. Aber ist es so eine Computerstimme? Walter, Walter? Nee, es ist ein Mann, der spricht. Aber an der tür aber ist es so eine computer stimme weiter weiter nee
ist ein mann der spricht und aber spielt der auch so ein bisschen so aufgericht steht er auf oder
ist es immer nur ganz nüchtern und trocken wo wir mal rein hören ich weiss nicht ob die ARD
Anwälte jetzt schon irgendwie die ähm ... ,,Fazierte Gesichter, Feuer, stürzende Männer, ein Verwunderter
im Rindstein wird mit einem Gewehrkolben gestossen. Rindstein? So und ich exakt das ist nämlich das
Vielen Dank. Feuer, stürzende Männer. Ein Verwunderter im Rindstein wird mit einem Gewehrkolben gestossen. Rindstein? So, und ich, exakt das ist nämlich das Geile daran. Und ich dachte erst so, oh fuck, wie nervig kriege ich das überhaupt hin. Inzwischen denke ich mir, ab jetzt will ich alles mit Audiodeskription gucken. Und ich glaube, du bist ähnlich. Weil es ist so krass, was das macht, wenn du nicht die ganze Zeit darüber nachdenken musst, mit was schlägt er ihm jetzt? Mit einem Gewehrkolben. Mit einem Gewehrkolben. Was ist das da? In einem Wort, weil man denkt sich, man versteht viel mehr. Ja. Und dann, aber das ist super spannend, weil teilweise spielen Schauspieler nicht so gut, ein paar spielen sehr schlecht. Und dann Meinst du damit August Diehl oder wen meinst du? August Diehl hat nicht die besten Stellen auch, aber insgesamt spielt er super. August Diehl ist generell ein sehr talentierter Schauspieler, nur hier vielleicht nicht, ich kann es nicht sagen, ich habe die Serie nicht gesehen.
Doch auch hier würde ich dir zustimmen, aber es gibt auch schwache Stellen, egal, es geht nicht um August Thiel.
Nämlich geht um ein anderer Schauspieler, ist egal, na komm jetzt, komm, nein, ich weiß nicht, wer er heisst.
Jetzt komm.
So und dann sagt diese Audiostimme, dann sagt diese Audiostimme, sagt dann, ein Mann schaut fahrig von rechts nach links. Und ich musste so lachen, weil ich dachte, ja, das ist auch super weird gespielt. Und dann denke ich mir, das ist ja die Kunst, das Wort fahrig ist auf eine Art, weil blinde Menschen haben ja auch ein Recht zu erfahren, wer gut spielt und wer nicht.
Ach so. Deswegen habe ich mir eigentlich gewünscht zu sagen,
der Schauspieler spielt schlecht und guckt von rechts
nach links. Er schaut schlecht
gespielt von links nach rechts. Unmotiviert.
Genau, es fing auch so weird an,
dann eine sehr attraktive junge Dame
sitzt im Zug. Und man denkt so,
bei keinem fucking Typen
war das Thema.
Und bei ihr ist auch nicht das Aussehen ein Thema. Ich meine, Walter Gropius ist Daddy. Das wissen wir alle. Walter Gropius ist Hot AF. Wirklich so viel Dad Energy. Oh ja. Und dann aber die Protagonistin, um die es geht. Und es geht auch um Feminismus und die Gleichberechtigung und die Stellung von Frauen am Bauhaus. Und der erste Satz über sie ist, eine attraktive junge Dame sitzt im Zugabteil. Und man denkt sich so, das kann ich, und dann ihr Freund kommt dann an, ein gut aussehender junger Kerl, Johannes stürmt auf sie zu. Ein Mann. Aber wer schreibt diese Texte? Also ist es dann nochmal, vor allem werden die geschrieben, nachdem die Serie fertig ist, oder werden die sozusagen mitgeschrieben? Oder wird das dann gleichzeitig veröffentlicht? Oder hat jemand, kriegt jemand die Serie in der Dropbox und sagt, okay, ich muss das jetzt schreiben. Und die Person muss dann entscheiden, schreibe ich fahrig oder schreibe ich lässig oder wie stark beschreibe ich was und nimmt das dann noch mal jemand ab? Das ist ja viel Arbeit. Ja, auf eine Art ja auch wie Untertitelarbeit. Also ich finde auch, dass es sehr schlecht ist, was gerade passiert. Also zum Beispiel Son of Interest fand ich sehr, sehr schlecht übersetzt mit Untertiteln, aber auch viele englische Filme haben sehr schlechte deutsche Untertitel.
Moment, aber Son of Interest doch auf Deutsch.
Genau.
Und das hast du mit englischen Untertiteln geschaut?
Ja, mal so reingeguckt. Ich finde das sehr interessant, wie Dinge übersetzt werden. Und es ist tatsächlich einfach manchmal sehr, sehr schlecht alles. In alle Richtungen und einfach falsch auch. Und da frage ich mich generell, wer guckt da drüber? Und ich behaupte, da gibt es so ein ganzes Kartell. Da gibt es so eine ganz schlimme Kartelllösung. Wahrscheinlich auch so ein Name, der eigentlich mehrere Leute sind, so Doktor Sommer mässig. Das ist Sigrun Robbelsbach, die eigentlich ein ganzes Konglomerat ist. Das ist ein ganzes Kartell dahinter. Ja, es gibt auf jeden Fall ... Wie kommt man da rein? Ich habe nämlich einen Freund aus den USA, der hat viel übersetzt für How to Sell Drugs zum Beispiel, damit das die Amis checken können und noten konnten bei Netflix. Und der hat das so toll übersetzt. Und der kann so gut, der Muttersprachler Englisch kommt aus Chicago, aber er kann so gut Deutsch, dass er wunder, wunderbar von Deutsch auf Englisch übersetzen kann. Und der müsste alle englischen Untertitel machen, aber er kommt da nicht rein. Und man kriegt ihn da auch nicht rein, er kriegt das nicht hin. Und das ist so krass, da ist so ein Kartell und wir wollen da reinzecken. Da muss man reingeboren werden wahrscheinlich, da kommt ja nur der Nachwuchs von den schon bestehenden Strukturen da rein. Weil wer guckt, da sind auch oft einfach Rechtschreibfehler drin. Ja, oder das Ganze müssen wir leider auch am Ende sagen, KI, aka, eine Horde Inder. Vielleicht ist das gar kein Kartell von schaltragenden Intellektuellen. NHI wieder, eine Horde Inder. Ja, es kann auch sein, dass es so funktioniert. Aber spannend, muss ich mal gucken, aber ist natürlich auch eine interessante Frage, wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, archive.org, man will die Version bewahren, welche denn? Mit Untertitel, ohne, mit Beschreibung, ohne Beschreibung? Mein Vorschlag wäre jetzt nicht unbedingt die audiodeskriptive Version. Aber meinetwegen, ich habe jedenfalls sehr viel Spaß gehabt, das zu hören und habe mir die gleichen Fragen gestellt, weil du kommentierst schon sehr viel. Ja. Also du, auch in dem, was du weglässt, was du erklärst, aber ich habe so viel Spaß daran, weil manchmal, gebe ich offen und ehrlich zu, mache ich auch was anderes neben dem Gucken von etwas, gerade wenn es so halbberuflich ist und ich auch so ein bisschen aus Inspirationsgründen geguckt habe und so aus geschichtlichem Hintergrund und dann macht man mal was anderes, sondern man dreht sich mal um und macht kurz Tortellini nochmal heiß oder sowas. Also ein Tortellino. Ein Riesentortellino. Und dann freue ich mich, dass da im Hintergrund jemand sagt, Walter Grubius steht auf, er dreht sich im Kreis, er dreht sich im Kreis, er tanzt. Hau das doch einfach nochmal als Podcast oder Hörbuch raus. Exakt. Ey, das ist ja ein Hörspiel, ein Film ist ja letztlich ein Hörspiel mit Bildern. Jetzt nimmt die Bilder weg und er beschreibt sie mit Audiodeskription, haut das alles nochmal schön als Hörbuch rein. Ich bin jetzt eingestiegen ins Hörbuch-Business und ich brauche Futter. Ich sage es euch, wie es ist, ich brauche Futter. Und deswegen alle Filme nochmal mit Audiodeskription einfach hochladen, die Lizenzstreitigkeiten müssen da in Brand sein. Raus mit dem Zeug. Brauchst du wirklich Tipps für Hörbücher? Ach ja, ich weiss nicht. Hör dir mal Tonio Kröger von Thomas Mann an, gelesen von Thomas Mann. Nein. Ich finde das tatsächlich, das ist irgendwie krass, weil das hat man so abgespeichert als jemand, der zur Zeit gelesen hat, wo es Mikrofone noch nicht so gab und die Augenrechnung noch nicht so vorgeschritten war. Ja, ist auch sehr kratzig und rau. Stimmt auch ein bisschen, ehrlich gesagt, es ist nicht so weit weg der Gedanke von der Realität, aber er liest es vor. Ich habe tatsächlich, ich mache längere Spaziergänge jetzt, immer so eine Stunde und habe letztens tatsächlich auf meine... Vor was läufst du weg? Bei meiner Verantwortung, vor meinem Entkäser. Ich habe sehr viele Probleme und deswegen mache ich ja sehr viele, ich habe sehr viele Dienstreisen gerade. Ich habe den Entkäser benutzt und der ist dreckig wie Sau und ich will ihn nicht sauber machen und deswegen mache ich einen Spaziergang, einfach um meinen Kopf durchzuwischen. Und ihn verschwinden zu lassen. Und ihn verschwinden zu lassen. Und letztens habe ich tatsächlich, weil ich mich nicht entscheiden konnte, einfach eine Stunde lang Hörproben gehört von Audiobüchern. Einfach so zweiminütige Hörproben. Hell der Ringe, Dune, Game of Thrones, einfach mal alle durch. Man kann ja kennen Muster, also alle bekannten Fantasy-Fantasy. Einfach mal so durchgehört und das war mein Tag. Das war meine Unterhaltung. Wahrscheinlich sehr schlecht für die Aufmerksamkeit. Wollst du denn die Sprecher testen
oder wolltest du den Inhalt des geschriebenen Wortes?
Ich wollte mir fragen, welche Stelle nimmst du?
Also wenn du jetzt
der Herr der Ringe die Gefährten und dann
sagst, ähm, Stefan, kannst du noch
für die Hörprobe da einfach so zwei Minuten
rausschneiden und du
stehst vor einer 36-stündigen
Audiodatei
und hast jetzt die Aufgabe. Ist es nicht immer der Anfang? Es ist nicht der Anfang, überhaupt nicht. Ist es nicht immer das Ende? Es ist nicht das Ende, überhaupt nicht, das ist ja ein Spoiler. Frodo starb, und so starb Frodo, und so starb Frodo eines furchtbaren Todes. Als Frodo starb, starb auch Legolas. Und das ist so, dass er die Hörprobe direkt rein. Von der die Gefährten, wenn ja gut, wenn man die Gefährten so kommt. Und so warf er nach der langen Odyssee, boy oh boy, was war da alles los, den Ring in den Schicksalsberg. Ende. Und deswegen, einfach mal als Quizfrage, überlegt euch mal, welche zwei Minuten ... Als Quizfrage?
Als Quizfrage, ja, wenn du es richtig hast, dann küsse ich dich, Stefan.
Oh, okay.
Von die Gefährten.
Welche zwei Minuten würdest du nehmen?
Wo du sagst, das ist jetzt repräsentativ für das gesamte Buch.
Eigentlich klassischer Second Act, also Anfang zweiter Akt Scheiß.
Fun and Games.
Genau.
Auf dem Drachen reiten. Dann der Erleichterungsmoment. Ja, aber sowas. Was bei denen wäre, die Gefährten liefen. Die Stelle, wo es kommt, man sieht nämlich literally, wie sie durch die, laufen sie über so eine Bergkuppe, diese Musik kommt und es ist Slow-Mo Und das ist der offene Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da Das erste Mal als Gefährten an der Kamera vorbei. Und es gibt keinen klaren, das ist der zweite Akt, startet gerade im Moment.
Abenteuer, los geht's.
Super gut, ganz, ganz toll. Und das wäre für mich der Moment.
Jetzt ist Slow-Mo halt als Hörbuch nicht immer so ganz einfach zu transportieren. Auf ihr Reise ein Enttritt auf Frodo erstirbt. Nee, es ist in Moria, kurz bevor sie angegriffen werden von den Orks, wo sie das Buch lesen, in dem drinsteht, was das Schicksal von Moria war, diese Szene. Und du schreist auf, ach, also laufen Sie durch Moria.
Aber es ist eine Entscheidung, die Frodo trifft.
Ja.
Also das ist mein Alltag mittlerweile.
Ich höre mir Hörproben aus Hörbüchern an und höre mich einmal komplett durch.
Ich liebe das Hörbuch.
Wenn man sich ...
Der Gandalf-Sprecher spricht das.
Ja.
Da ist die Frage, wie bist du ...
Weil auch Ian McKellen gelesen hat, ne?
Hat nicht auch Ian McKellen das in Beryllion gelesen? Hat man gesagt, okay, der deutsche Gandalf-Schauspieler muss auch das deutsche Hörbuch lesen. Das ist so, wie wenn du so ein Doppelgänger bist. Dann musst du immer den gleichen Lebensstil haben, wie der von dem Doppelgänger bist. Wenn du sagst, der nimmt zehn Kilo zu, musst du auch zehn Kilo zunehmen. Wenn jetzt plötzlich Zendaya dreißig, vierzig Kilo zunimmt, müssen alle Zendaya-Doppelgängerinnen, die ...mäßig gebucht werden, zu Kindergeburtstagen oder was auch immer, müssen auch zunehmen. Das ist das Leben. Naja, meine Frage wäre aber an dich bei Büchern und der Übersetzung. Ist es dir da wichtig, das auf Originalsprache zu hören oder ist es für dich auch deutsche Übersetzung? Ach, das ist mir da nicht so wichtig so. Ich habe nur Angst, dass ich aussteige und nicht mehr reinkomme und dann zurückskippe und dann weiss ich nicht, ob ich da schon war und dann wieder vorskippe und dann höre ich doch Podcast wieder.
Und was hörst du für Podcast gerade so? Ja, also News, also News, was so los ist. The News.
Ich muss halt noch nachhören.
Also ich bin gerade viel bei 2003, gerade die News mit Irakkrieg und so. Also da bin ich voll drin. Beste News. Gutes Jahr. Gutes News Jahr. Gutes News Jahr. Falls jemand Bock hat, da nochmal richtig zu diskutieren, da habe ich alles parat. Aber selten ist das noch Thema. Der wird ja auch nicht wirklich aufgearbeitet, muss man auch mal sagen. Da bräuchte es vielleicht noch mal eine Serie.
Vielen Dank für deine News-Recap.
Also, völkerrechtswidrig auf jeden Fall und alles in allem misslungen und auf Lügen gebaut. Also krass, dass man den Podcast sucht, das hört man ja eigentlich nicht, um jetzt so einen Verdict zum Irakkrieg zu bekommen.
Aber okay, wenn ihr...
Die Leute warten seit 21 Jahren darauf, dass wir mal Stellung beziehen zum Irakkrieg und dass wir da was einordnen.
Das ist ein sehr wichtiger Punkt. Um den Irakkrieg zu bekommen. Aber okay, wenn ihr denkt, ich will die Antwort. Die Leute warten seit 21 Jahren darauf, dass wir mal Stellung beziehen zum Irakkrieg und dass wir da was einordnen, dass wir mal sagen, wirklich, was soll ich denken. Die Leute seit 21 Jahren wissen nicht, was sie denken sollen. Sie brauchen Podcaster, die ihnen sagen, was sie denken sollen. Die sie lenken. Und jetzt habe ich es gesagt. Wir sind wie die Ratte auf dem Ratatouille-Kopp, sind wir bei euch. Podcaster sind die Ratten sind die Ratten am Kopf. Ja, das stimmt. Wir lenken euch mit unseren Meinungen und ihr jetzt da draußen, die Podcast-Hofo-Hörerinnen und Hörer, ja, es war völkerrechtlich. Du meinst jetzt so eine Art Karikatur, wo so eine Ratte auf dem Kopf sitzt und dann mit so Marionettenfäden dann so die Ohren, so die Airbuds in den Ohren, da sind Schnüre dran, im Sinne von ich steuere dich durch die Ohren. Genau, durch die Ohren wirst du gesteuert und so. Und dann vielleicht noch, dann zoomt man so auf, man sieht, da ist ein Wahlzettel vor demjenigen und der Stift wird sozusagen, da ist eine Schnur dran mit einer Hand und die wird so von uns gestört. Die Ratte hat auch noch die Schnüre von den Händen, die steuert die Airbats und die Hände gleichzeitig. Da müssen wir uns entscheiden langfristig, ob das sozusagen im Kopf funktioniert. Das können wir nicht lange vor uns herschieben. Das können wir nicht mehr lange vor uns herschieben. Wir sind da meist Trost drin, des Voreinanderherschiebens. Meistens auch ohne Probleme, weil es passiert nichts rechts und links. Aber bei dieser Karikatur müssen wir uns entscheiden. Ich wäre dafür, wir sind sozusagen aus den Kopfhörern. Auch gut,
kommen so Arme raus, die dann mit den Marionettenfäden
die Hände des Hörers dann
steuern, der dann
Ballzettel was ankreuzt. Ja genau,
der Ballzettel ankreuzt. Und was macht die Ratte
währenddessen? Die Ratte, die weiss ich jetzt
auch noch nicht, ob wir die überhaupt brauchen.
Ich meine, jetzt haben wir das Ganze, die ganze Karriatur heisst
The Rat. Das ist das Problem. Du kannst das auch nicht rausretuschieren aus den Haaren, weil das war fucking viel. Nee, die Ratte könnte ... Die haben wir gerendert. Die haben uns damals gesagt, es ist billiger, wenn ihr einfach das 3D-Modell rendert, als wenn ihr immer neu zeichnet. Wir haben gesagt, es ist eine 2D-Kalikatur, wir brauchen kein 3D-Modell. Das hat zwei Millionen Euro gekostet. Und die haben gesagt, nein, es ist billiger, wenn ihr die komplett einmal rendert, jedes Haar einfach einmal gerendert hat.. Das rentiert sich ab drei Folgen. Ja gut, dann machen wir das so. Und jetzt ist die halt gerendert, The Rat. Haben wir noch eine Idee für Folge zwei? Weil wir haben damals relativ grossmundig, dicklippig gesagt. Dicklippig, grossmundig und kleinäugig gesagt, dass wir das gerne machen würden. Dass wir die Ratte für drei Karikaturen brauchen, für unser Karikaturmagazin. Und jetzt haben wir eine Idee, und auch die ist so halb da. Wir haben eine Idee und kein Karikaturmagazin. Wir haben uns da irgendwie so ein bisschen verrannt. Leider. Also, falls ihr Ideen habt, knackige, am Zeitgeist kratzende Ideen mit einer Ratte für unser Karikatur-Satire-Magazin The Rat, Add The The. Es hieß früher Rat und jetzt heisst's The Rat. Add The The. Nein, Cut The The. Cut The The. Mark Zuckerberg auch jetzt inzwischen ...
Ich will ihm gerne noch mal so etwas hinterher werfen. Du bist noch nicht durch mit ihm, habe ich das Gefühl. Das ist mein Cut the, the. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ihr beide noch eine Rechnung offen habt, Mark und du. Da wurde jetzt diese KI-Brille entwickelt mit Simultanübersetzung. Und du kannst ... Denn so hört man ja, mit dem Auge. So, und jetzt möchte ich das aber, diese Idee jetzt aber als Karikatur. Also, Mark Zuckerberg setzt einer Ratte eine VR-Brille auf. Sehr gut, weil wir haben das Modell. Ja, setzt eine VR-Brille auf und sagt, dann hörst du mich besser? So, Sprechblase? Nee, erste Kachel ist Opa. Ach, wir haben mehrere Kachel. Opa hast du mir überhaupt zugehört? Zweite Kachel ist, du weißt doch, ich bin schwerhörig. Dritte Kachel ist, ich hab die Lösung für dich. Zuckerberg, den man erkennt, weil er den Finger hochmacht und sagt, ich hab eine Idee, und dann gibt er ihm diese Brille, setzt ihm die Brille auf. Opa sitzt, hat eine
Brille auf. Opa sagt, was hast du gesagt?
Sehr gut. Und wo ist die Ratte?
Fuck!
Gut, also das ist alles
noch Ideen, die entstehen sind,
auf jeden Fall. Aber was stört dich mit Saki?
Also hast du da noch ein,
noch offen willst du da noch was in die Gegend schiessen? Ihr wart ja damals zusammen in Harvard und irgendwie weil du immer so murmelst, der hat meine Idee geklaut, der hat meine Idee geklaut, also was war die Idee genau? Ich murmel das leise, aber dann doch hörbar, wo man denkt, ah, vielleicht will ich nicht, dass es gehört wird. Genau. Ne, ich denke mir einfach, er kauft halt meine Apps nicht. Und die sind ja so bait, also die sind ja so kaufbait, weil es ja genau was in das Portfolio von Facebook passt. Richtig, deine Idee ist immer, du entwickelst eine App, lässt sie dann von Facebook kaufen und wirst reich. Genau, genau. Und es hat noch nicht geklappt. So wie Wordle oder sowas. Ja genau, einfach eine App, ja oder Instagram wurde auch gekauft oder Snapchat sowas, irgendwie was, was gross ist, was dann gekauft wird vom Metakonzern. Und bislang hat er noch keine das Podcast-Ufo-App gekauft. Richtig, obwohl da wirklich gute Ideen dabei waren. Da waren so geile Sachen dabei. Der Zufallsemoji zum Beispiel. Eine App mit einem grossen Knopf und du drückst drauf und es gibt dir einen zufälligen Emoji, den du dann benutzt kannst. Und den du automatisch, ehe man zufällig gesendest. Aus deiner Kontaktliste. Und dann plötzlich hast du wieder Freundschaften, wo du sagst, oh, ich war froh, dass sie vorbei ist.
Wow, ich habe nur meine Gurke bekommen, lass uns darüber reden, lass uns einsteigen. Genau, ja, ja, also solche Sachen, der Randomizer, sowas, wo ich einfach denke, das wäre wahnsinnig cool und würde genau ins Portfolio passen, hat er noch nicht gekauft. Die Snackliefer-App, ah, ich habe jetzt Bock auf Chips, jemand kommt vorbei mit einem mobilen Popcornwagen, der dann heiße Popcorn bei dir über den Zaun wirft. Meine Moment-App übrigens. Was soll das nochmal? Die, als ich immer noch für eine geniale Idee halte, die Idee beim Moment ist, manchmal, wenn man im Zug jemanden attraktiven sieht, dann denkt man, hat sie mich gerade auch angeguckt? Hatten wir mich gerade irgendwie einen Moment? Dann kann man sein Handy hervorholen, entweder offensiv sichtbar oder für dich. Das ist eine weisse App, die ist ganz weiss, wunderschön aus. Oben links steht mit schwarzer Krackelschrift Moment. Und in der Mitte ist ein schwarzer Button. Da steht drauf Moment. Ich nehme es zurück, da steht drauf Moment. Dann kannst du auf Moment klicken und Moment, dann hast du einen Moment, den löst du aus wie so eine Welle, also eine Bluetooth-GPS-Welle. Und wenn die Person und du gleichzeitig auf Moment drückst, im selben Radius, dann bildet sich ein Chat. Ah, in der Nähe, okay. Genau, es ist wie Tinder, nur im analogen Leben, also im Real Life. Man muss sich sehen, man muss sich begegnen, es ist wirklich wieder rauszuge gehen. Das ist deswegen auch eine sehr zeitgemäße App, weil das ist ja gar nicht mehr so, dass alle immer nur noch drinnen sind und Tinder ist ja fucking outdated. Aber woher weißt du, dass du den Moment genau mit der Person hattest? Weil sagen wir mal, da saßst du jemandem gegenüber, ihr habt euch angelächelt, währenddessen Harald drei Reihen weiter drückt auf und habt ihr dann eineniermoment, oder hast du mit Harald oder sie mit Harald? Wir, jeder mit jedem. Alle drei, alle die einen Moment hatten, gleichzeitig kommen in den Chatroom. Dann hast du mit ihr und mit Harald einen offenen Chat. Du hast zwei Moments, zwei offenen Chats. Das ist jetzt schon stressig. Nee, nee, dann machst du Harald weg. Aber du siehst ja auch den Namen, siehst du dann Jennifer und Harald? Ja, sobald beide einen Moment haben und bestätigt haben, im Sinne von confirmed, ja, das ist genau die Person, die ich meinte, dann wird geshared, dann wird geshared alle Informationen übereinander, die man sharen will, wie zum Beispiel Bilder, Hobbys, Größe und sowas, also so Tinder-Sachen halt. Moment. Und jetzt kommt der Clou, du hast jeden Tag nur drei Moments. Jeder weitere Moment kostet zehn Dollar. Ja, lächerlich viel, weil du willst ja eben nicht, es muss viel sein. Wenn du draufdrückst, dann muss es wohl überlegt sein und du kannst nicht einen Stalker haben, die die ganze Zeit, war genau meine Idee, ich laufe den ganzen Tag durch die Gegend und drücke ganz schnell drauf. Ja, ja, verstehe. Durch Fussgänger zu holen und denkst, wer atmet so schwer hinter mir. Ja, hast du einen Moment-Stalker. Okay, ja, das heißt, du hast einen Moment, aber denkst, oh fuck, ich habe kein Guthaben mehr. Und dann holst du dir schnell für zehn Dollar was. Was ist zehn Euro im Vergleich zur grossen Liebe? Gute Frage. Was ist die grosse Liebe dir wert? Ja, mehr als zehn Euro. Tausend, zweihundert Euro. So, dann kostet ein Moment, tausend, zweihundert. Also du hast hundertzwanzig Versuche, bevor du sagst, das lohnt sich nicht, diese App ist Abzocke, weg damit. Genau, es gibt minimale Werbung, okay. Also minimal, so Clark oder so, Werbung, ganz wenig, HelloFresh, oben kurz in der Ecke steht es da. Ihr könntet zum Beispiel reden über Lebensversicherung. Das ist dann so ein bisschen als kleine Bannerwerbung im Chatroom. Du kannst aber auch selber was verdienen, weil wenn du nämlich in der Audionachricht so ein bisschen Buzzwords hetzt, wie zum Beispiel komplett papierlos und unsere Klagexperten, kriegst du Geld. Das ist aber doch die bessere Idee, oder? Das ist die bessere Idee. Nein, du kannst dir sagen, bei etwas, was ich nebenbei im Nebensatz sagen, das ist die viel bessere Idee. Das ist eine viel, viel bessere Idee. Werbung im Alltag. Wenn du sozusagen einen guten Kumpel von dir schreibst, ich habe gerade irgendeinen Service benutzt, ich war gerade bei McDonalds und habe den neuen Fisch. Das kriegt man auch hin, weil Sprachnachrichten werden ja auch, also bei Slack inzwischen, jede Sprachnachricht oder Audiodatei bei Slack wird automatisch transkribiert unten drunter. Das heißt, wenn du da eine Firma entdeckst, ah, du verfolgst ein gewisses Protokoll, was man rumschickt, kriegt man so, kann man Geld verdienen. Aber ganz wenig, weil es immer nur auf eine Person ist, aber du kannst minimal Geld verdienen. Das heißt, du hakst was an auf deinem Handy, dass das dir konstant zuhören kann und am Ende des Monats kriegst du eine Auflistung. Du hast fünfze über diese Serie gesprochen, du hast acht Mal Gurken empfohlen, du hast 672 Mal Milka Tender empfohlen deinen Freunden und dann hast du unten unterm Strich hast du 16 Euro verdient an Werbung, die du gemacht hast. Und so ein Vorschlag für ein besseres Leben, wie Phane Therapie an, oder? Also so ein bisschen Analyse. Analytics, genau. Das ist eine Werbung von therapy.com. Okay. Und ist deren Vorschlag meistens ... Am Ende verdienen alle sehr wenig, ausser ich. Verdienen alles in meinen Taschen. Du greifst dir immer was ab. Bis, und dann ist alles geil, wenn The Sack mein Kram kauft. Ja. Aufsackt. Sack kauf mein Kram. Und dann kriegst du richtig viel Geld. Hast du schon eine Idee, was du mit dem Geld machst? Also sparst du auf irgendwas gerade?
Habe ich schon mal gesagt, aber ich wäre der fucking beste Reiche.
Weil ganz ehrlich, wie dumm sind Superreiche, die kaufen sich fucking Yachten. Super Yachten mit Personal.
Ja, aber selbst Yachten mit Personal sind so fucking fucking dumm.
Es ist so dumm.
Du hast ja keinen krasseren Lebensstandort als in einem viel, viel billigeren Luxushotel.
Du hast ja kein, das ist immer noch ein fucking Schiff mit Schiffmöglichkeiten. Und je grösser es wird, desto mehr wird es wie ein Haus. Ja, jetzt ein Glückwunsch. Es wird ja nicht besser. Und Superreiche haben dann so Ego-Shit am Start. Und das ist halt das Problem. Was würdest du machen? Spenden. Ja, na, na klar. Wenn es das nicht gäbe, dieses Konzept. Ich glaube, du würdest einfach ein kleines Land kaufen. Du würdest dir einfach schauen, Bip, von irgendwie kleinen Ländern und dann würdest du einfach sagen, Peru, kaufe ich. Und dann bist du einfach der König von Peru und machst da dein Ding und krempelst das Land richtig mal um und lässt sich da Statuen aufbauen. Nee, ich würde schon gerne, also öffentliche Einrichtungen wie Opernhäuser, Kinos oder so, finde ich mega geil. Aber ich will die auch selber, und das ist der Twist, der vielen nicht gefallen wird, bauen als Architekt. Okay, hast du dich schon für eine Stilrichtung entschieden, in die du bauen willst? Guck, nur auf die Lust, was auch ins Umfeld passt, aber schon Bauhaus. Okay, alles klar. Ich musste letztendlich denken, ich habe gesehen, was jetzt an Filmen rauskommt und unter anderem Paddington Bear in Peru kommt jetzt raus. Und da habe ich an dich gedacht und dachte mir, ach guck mal, der Stefan war auch schon in Peru und jetzt kommt Paddington Bear nach Peru. Bin mal gespannt, was der so verabend war. Ja, hast du mal bei den Writers geguckt? Oh oh, Stefan schreibt Paddington? Paddington. Hättest du mal Bock, einen Paddington-Film
zu schreiben? Klar, Paddington
kommt aus Kolumbien zurück.
Paddington und seine Phasen.
Paddington hat
ein Wussetball gekauft. Paddington lernt
Steppen.
Auf ein kompletter Film einfach.
Ja, klar, warum nicht?
Warum nicht?
Weißt du, wenn jemand kann ich wenigstens mal wieder was machen. Du machst so viel, Stefan. Ja, ich will nur mal wieder, dass mal wieder was, mal wieder fertig wird, das wäre immer schön. Ja, das stimmt, ja. Manchmal geht es auch darum, kann man jetzt auch tiefer analysieren, aber müssen wir jetzt ja nicht machen. Also wenn du willst, wenn du was, also willst du was? Nein, du eine Idee, die du gerne umsetzen willst, weil wir haben noch eine Ratte. Wir hatten jetzt die Idee mit den Magneten und die Idee mit der Brille und jetzt wir haben noch eine Ratte übrig und da kannst du dich ja austoben. Also wie gesagt, die ist gerendert, da können wir alles mitmachen, was du möchtest, wenn du eine Idee hast. dass Zuckerberg meine Epidien aufkauft und dann, ich wäre so gut darin, Geld zu haben. So eine Verschwendung, dass du nicht mehr Geld hast. Money is wasted on the rich. Ich wäre so gut darin, bin ich mir sicher, dass ich meinen Lebensstandard besser verbessern könnte, als Superreiche das mit ihrem Geld machen. Superreiche, eh komisches Konzept. Aber da reden wir dann nächste Woche, bei unserer Themenwoche, brauche es Superreiche, sollte es noch Milliardäre geben. Richtig, wie viel Geld macht glücklich? Wann ist genug? Ab wann kriegt man den Hals auch dann nicht mehr voll für uns? Das ist der knackige Titel. Wann ist so viel zu viel dann auch gut irgendwann? Das ist so ein bisschen der Themenabend, wo wir verschiedene Leute eingeladen haben. Wir haben den reichsten Menschen Kölns eingeladen. Wir haben Ranga Yogeshwar eingeladen. Ranga Yogeshwar eingeladen, Ayman Abdallah ist im Publikum. Und Georgina Fleur. Georgina Fleur ist auch im Publikum, die sind dabei. Und ansonsten natürlich noch Zendaya mit auf der Bühne, die natürlich auch mal ihre Perspektive geben kann, die ist ja auch nicht arm. Kann man ja auch mal sagen. Superreich. Kann man ja auch mal sagen. Willst du Zendaya das Geld wegnehmen? Ich will jetzt nicht nur ihr das Geld wegnehmen, aber ich würde der schon ein paar hunderttausend abknappen. Also wenn ich die Möglichkeit hätte, der Geld wegzunehmen, würde ich das auch tun, mal so ein bisschen. Ich mag sie, ich finde, sie macht tolle Arbeit und ich finde, sie verdient jeden Cent, den sie hat. Ja, anscheinend nicht. Du willst ja jeden Promi nennen können. Wann ist es ab genug, auch mal zu viel, ist die Frage. Und da ist Zendaya bei mir schon drüber. Da würde ich sagen, gib mir ein paar Runde. Du hättest ja jeden Schauspieler, jede Schauspielerin nehmen können, Nimm Zendaya, die macht doch einen super Job noch. Ja. Wann willst denn der das Geld wegnehmen? Bei, okay, dann bei welchem Schauspiel würdest du sagen, ist das Geld am meisten Missverhältnis zum Talent? Ah, okay. Jude Law ist für dich überbezahlt. Nee, ich habe ja den Satz nicht zu Ende gehört. Wäre es für mich komplett überbezahlt, so ein richtig schlechter Schauspieler. Ich weiss, dass du August Diehl sagst. Ich weiss, dass du diesen Beef einfach weitertreiben willst. Schauspieler. Mit wem? Daniel Brühl. Nein. Das mag ich nicht so gerne. Nein. Was? Ja. Oh, jetzt hast du es dir verhauen. Daniel, wenn du zuhörst, komm gerne vorbei, wir reden das aus, Konfrontation, Stefan Tietze und du, ihr habt offensichtlich viel zu bereden. Doch, ich fand den sehr vielen Film, fand ich den sehr gut, im Westen nichts Neues, fand ich den richtig schlecht. Aber es lag auch im Kostüm, weil die den dann so einen Schnauzer, weil die den immer anders verkleiden, aber es sieht immer aus wie ein Daniel Brühl, der zu Karneval als was geht, aber es liegt meistens wahrscheinlich am Kostümdepartment, eher als an Daniel Brühl.
Okay, also du sagst, das Kostümdepartment von Daniel Brühl ist überbezahlt.
Vielleicht kriegen wir da noch jemanden in unserer Show.
Ein normales Gehalt, ein gutes Gehalt wahrscheinlich.
Aber dass du Sendaya auswählst.
Wie gesagt, schaltet ein, es ist der Themenabend, es wird für 20 Minuten in der Mediathek sein.
Danach ist es weg für immer, begraben, nicht mehr anschaubar, aber diese Folge zum Beispiel. Sidney Sweeney. Florence Pugh? Blake Lively. Mark Wahlberg? Blake Lively. Da habe ich glaube ich gerade viel im Internet auf meiner Seite, wenn man sagt, die ist verhältnismässig zu gut bezahlt. Jude Law ist keine ... Ach nur, dass wir alle voll Frauen aufzählen, wir sind einfach sehr viele Frauen aufzählen. Diese Folge könnt ihr euch, wenn ihr möchtet, noch mal anhören, einfach direkt noch mal anhören, und falls ihr Lust habt, ihr könnt sie jetzt direkt von vorne starten, ihr könnt sie so oft anhören, wie ihr möchtet. Wir werden sie euch nie wegnehmen. Ihr habt immer wieder die Möglichkeit, reinzuhören. Egal, was los ist. Einfach. Jetzt noch mal komplett von Null. Los geht's. Nehmt euch jetzt alle an die Hände und lauft alle gemeinsam in einer großen Menschenkette auf die Strasse. Und küsst den Vordermann oder der Vorderfrau auf die Stirn. Jetzt noch mal vorne anfangen mit dem herrlichen Intro von Daniel.
Vielen, vielen Dank an Daniel noch mal für das Intro, da könnt ihr direkt wieder anfangen.
Haut rein, macht's gut, ansonsten bis nächste Woche.
Tschüss, Daniel!